mucha de la historia de mi vida y muchas
escenas han tenido que ver con la
pregunta de moverse o no moverse eso es
un tanto evidente
y yo puede identificar escenas concretas
en que en un instante me han dejado
quieto paralizado asustado
y a la vez muy movido por dentro
hoy les quiero compartir lo que aprendí
en uno de sus acontecimientos
mueven por fuera pero que sobre todo
conmueven por dentro o por lo menos a mí
así me pasó
a poco no hay lecciones que da la vida
que son importantes a veces a poco no
hay de estas clases que nos da la
existencia que por alguna razón son
difíciles de olvidar y que te marcan
yo tuve la suerte como muchos mexicanos
de estar en ese examen sorpresa que nos
planteó la vida el 19 de septiembre del
2017 a las 13 14 horas
se siente horrible
yo llego un momento en que sentí que me
caía de la silla de ruedas
a mí con toda sinceridad el terremoto me
agarró comiendo un taco de asesina
y el plan era recoger a pablo mi hijo
para irnos a esquiar
solo para que vean mi inconsciencia así
lo hice
recogí a pablo tuvimos que dar esta
vuelta por un puente que se había caído
ahora lo que me doy cuenta es que tal
vez tenía un miedo tan monstruoso que la
mejor manera de defenderme fue decir no
pasa nada y seguir con las actividades
de ese día
al día siguiente la cruz roja ayudará un
poco y un par de días después por la
bendición de tener amigos de esos que se
pueden llamar locos útiles tuve la
suerte de ir con mi amigas o carlo
clericó un ingeniero tanatólogo loco a
jojutla
el plan era ir con un grupo de maestros
cuya escuela se había caído
varios de ellos habían perdido su casa
de las familias también algunos incluso
habían perdido algún familiar
fue muy impresionante llegar a jojutla y
era como llegar a una película de la
guerra todo tirado edificios caídos
polvo por todos lados la alameda llena
de casas de campaña y en la calle
muchísimas muchísimas personas de todos
lados de la republica algunos
extranjeros muchos universitarios
de mi esposa inteligente sensible
práctica y útil como es se puso con las
directoras de la escuela hacer un plan
para regresar a clases y para soñar una
escuela renovada
yo estaba súper confundida porque eso de
recoger piedras y escombros la verdad no
se me facilita mucho entonces pensé que
lo mejor era aprender leal carlos y
ayudar a las personas a recoger sus
escombros y acomodar sus escombros
internos y así empecé a trabajar ya
participar en grupos de acompañamiento
en crisis bueno así se llaman yo más
bien puedo decir que tuve el privilegio
de tomar cátedra con maestros de
resiliencia de jojutla zacatepec
tlaltizapán
cuernavaca y la ciudad de mexico y
quisiera compartirles en unos minutos
tres lecciones que esta experiencia me
regaló les comparto con cariño un abc de
las lecciones que aprendí
la a ha de abrir los ojos primero para
ver para dónde salir corriendo
en mi caso rodar rápido pero
también abrir los ojos para asombrarnos
de lo que estaba pasando a de alto de
hacer un alto útil en un mundo que va
muy rápido pero con un destino poco
claro en una sociedad apurada por el
reloj y el cronómetro pero sin una
brújula clara y de pronto la mejor
brújula el corazón y el amor como
destino común ha de abrazar me acuerdo
una chava que me platicaba que le había
agarrado el temblor en el piso 27 de un
edificio y cuando pudo bajar se moría de
ganas de darle un abrazo
y al primero que abrazó fue al jefe de
seguridad del edificio y luego se hizo
una especie de epidemia de abrazos y
muchas de estas personas cuando habían
entrado al edificio solo habían visto al
guardia de seguridad de reojo
los temblores nos ayudan a ver personas
donde la vida cotidiana a veces solo
vemos uniformes
ha de aprender de aprender de esa
generación que con su testimonio nos
enseñó que se puede reconstruir un país
con un modelo de desarrollo sustentable
un modelo cuyas energías renovables son
la alegría la felicidad la compañía la
comunidad el trabajo y el esfuerzo
compartido como me sorprendió escuchar a
muchos profesores a muchas maestras que
no solo hablaban de su miedo y del miedo
que habían vivido en el temblor sino de
un terror mayor del terror a no estar a
la altura de lo que sus alumnos habían
demostrado que eran capaces
ha de acompañar de acompañar sin juicio
y con compasión un terremoto es un
desastre natural muy democrático lo
sentimos todos sin importar código
postal saldo bancario o nivel
socioeconómico pero las consecuencias no
siempre son tan democráticas dependen de
la historia de cada quien y también a
veces dependen de terremotos sociales
previos que hacen que los temblores no
sean tan equitativas
ha de aceptar aceptar las emociones y
los sentimientos sin juzgarlos
que confrontan teme resultó aprender lo
inútil y lo absurdo que es el juicio
moral de las emociones eso de poner la
etiqueta de emociones o sentimientos
buenos y sentimientos malos es como
decirle a alguien mira está muy bien que
tengas hambre pero está muy mal que
tenga sed
las emociones y los sentimientos son
guías y son alertas que nos invitan a la
acción el terror nos invita a salir
corriendo ya ponernos a salvo el miedo
nos puede paralizar pero el miedo
también nos invita a levantar la mano ya
pedir ayuda yo cuando lo vi lo que vi es
a muchas manos que estaban dispuestas a
ayudar a otros y entrelazarse el miedo
en este sentido genera comunidad
de alegría cuando hacíamos encuestas
entre algunos chavos les decíamos a ver
les y vamos diciendo emociones y ellos
nos decían así con su mano poco regular
o mucho y me sorprendió cuando decíamos
alegría
que las manos estaban hasta acá y cuando
les preguntamos por qué nos decían por
qué estamos felices de estar vivos
a de alegría a de asombro da a de
agradecer lo que a veces la vida nos
regala y que damos por hecho
ve
de buscar de buscar lo que la vida nos
está preguntando buscar ser útiles
buscar a las personas atrapadas pero no
sólo en las personas atrapadas debajo de
una losa de concreto buscar a las
personas que están atrapadas debajo de
los escombros de la indiferencia de la
soledad del miedo y de muchas otras
cosas
bucear al fondo de nuestro corazón para
sentir las mismas turbulencias las
mismas mareas las mismas olas que
nuestros hermanos en los grupos de
acompañamiento cuando alguien expresaba
una emoción sincera lo que se veía eran
un montón de miradas y de cabezas que
asentían y se ve como una ola una ola
que sin decir nada lo que te dice es te
entiendo porque yo lo siento igual
hay terremotos que provocan tsunamis que
nos re vuelcan con una fuerza horrible
hay otros temblores que lo que provocan
son olas de cariño que te abrazan te
acompañan y te llevan con cuidadito
hasta la tierra firme de tus seguridades
ve de borrar de borrar lo adjetivo para
con be hacer brillar lo sustantivo como
me asombraba una amiga que me decía mira
yo cada vez que íbamos a estos lugares
antes del terremoto a todos les veía
cara desde secuestradores
y después del terremoto y de tener la
oportunidad de conocerlos lo que veo son
personas valiosas que simplemente están
buscando igual que yo salir adelante
ve de barrer de barrer con los escombros
de lo que no fue firme un señor me decía
se cayó mi edificio pero no ese donde yo
estaba trabajando no no no el mío el
interior el que llevaba 50 años
construyendo ahora me voy a tener que
reconstruir con cimientos firmes
se debe callar
de callarnos levantando el puño
pidiendo el silencio que anhela
encontrar lo valioso y que anhela
encontrar vida
de cerrar la boca de cerrar la boca
para regalar el silencio que repara el
silencio que acompaña el silencio que te
dice lo que ninguna palabra puede
alcanzar a decir
de comunidad de comunidad que le gana a
la soledad cuando la vida pregunta y
pregunta fuerte
no se puede contestar en la primera
persona del singular se tiene que
contestar en la primera persona del
plural en el nosotros una de las
anécdotas que más me conmueven es la de
una amiga que platicaba como unos días
antes con el temblor de oaxaca les
habían pedido en la escuela de sus hijos
que compraran unas unas latas de atún
para las despensas de ayuda y cuando fue
al súper ella pensaba y una lata de atún
puede hacer la diferencia
y luego nos decía quién iba a decir que
diez días después se caía mi casa
y cuando baje en el albergue donde
estaba la despensa a buscar algo para la
cena de mis hijos saqué una lata de atún
que trae un mensaje que decía ánimo
desde tasco una lata de atún si puede
hacer la diferencia porque no solo apaga
el hambre sino que nutre de ánimo y de
esperanza para reconstruirnos y salir
adelante
se debe convertir de convertir nuestros
aprendizajes en servicio en uno de los
libros que más me gusta de 'zorba el
griego' sorba le preguntaba a su patrón
y tú en qué conviertes lo que comes
después de todas estas experiencias y
aprendizajes
yo estoy lleno de tareas y de preguntas
en que convertir en mis terremotos cómo
podré ser una onda sísmica que salga a
poner a prueba lo que no tiene buena
cimentación
cómo podré ayudar a construir un mundo
con las normas más exigentes de la ética
de la compañía de la solidaridad del
amor y del trabajo
como podría hacerle para tener un
sismólogo interno que me ayude a ser
sensible a los miles de terremotos
diarios que no se ven y que viven muchas
personas a mi alrededor como podré
hacerle para no regresar a la
indiferencia de lo cotidiano
y poder seguir viviendo en modo
terremoto vulnerable sensible y útil la
mejor estrategia que ha encontrado para
eso ha sido
seguir siendo aprendiz y tratar de
rodearme de buenos maestros les comparto
lo que me enseñó una de ellas una amiga
que nos decía que su mayor ilusión era
hacer una maestría pero como se había
caído su casa con eso se derrumbaba
también este proyecto
se ve que es súper estudiosa y súper
responsable porque nos platicaba como
disfrutaba hacer sus trabajos en ese
espacio privado y exclusivo que era su
cuarto y luego nos decía
después del terremoto mis últimos
trabajos los hice acostada en el suelo
en unas hojas de papel que llegaron con
las despensas y que tuve que poner a
secar al sol porque se habían mojado con
la lluvia
mi amiga funny
fue el mejor promedio de su generación y
hoy a unos meses del terremoto está en
milán haciendo un postgrado con una beca
que se gana
yo quisiera que esta plática sirviera
para decir gracias y hacer un homenaje a
estos maestros que me han enseñado que
las pesadillas se pueden convertir en
sueños cuando hay la alquimia de la
comprensión del cariño de la comunidad y
la ilusión compartida que las pesadillas
se pueden convertir en sueños cuando
despertamos para vivir en modo terremoto
conscientes vulnerables sensibles y
útiles que las pesadillas se pueden
volver sueños se pueden convertir en
sueños cuando despertamos
para movernos y para con movernos con
las ondas sísmicas del corazón de los
demás muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]